hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel tonight is the Thursday
night before EBX poster which is the EB
Games expo in Sydney and I've just spent
my night playing star wars battlefront I
really like it it's totally authentic
it's very very well done but I am
concerned that's all was well done he's
going to be just like titanfall or
destiny where initially it seems awesome
and it's a lot of fun to play but he
doesn't have a lot of longevity and once
you play two hours of it you know
exactly what it is and you know what the
rest of you I was gonna be like it's
just here to say at this point we will
have to wait and see I'm really excited
for the actual export is dot I'll be
here on Friday and on Saturday and will
hopefully get to play a whole bunch of
the beautiful stuff that you can kind of
see in the background
so I've worked at eb expo before when i
used to do stuff for xbox australia and
i'm not going to lie this right here is
the bane of my existence it's like a
Just Dance booth and all they ever do is
play the same songs over and over again
really loud and by the end of three days
at an expo where especially xbox is
always right across from UV subs right
there it's just right now I'm here
actually very quiet I didn't hear
everything is the expo started
you know it's kind of plain area but I
still goes and I would bring you guys
playing ramos exceeds dustin which is
extremely technical i'm a huge fan of
rainbow six games i think about six
vegas she was probably my favorite
shooter and that was very very intense
it was really really close down to the
washdown ended up at 11 so it's a really
particularly tactical shooter which
means that you know there's a lot of
communication that you need which is
defined in person shooter that i love
but i'm very excited for to come out
definitely my favorite I playin
so next up i just had a demo of
PlayStation VR which usually project
Morpheus and I know that I can share in
some cold deep and it basically is
submerged into water
my experience is very very light the
classic picture quality I completely
believe that I would it makes me so
uncomfortable for whatever reason every
time and I mean one of those things I
just kind of freeze until
incredible experience I cannot wait for
this game for me
so much of you probably already know
that i am not a big player but right he
was one of the ones that was open last
night for us to play so we didn't have
waited appraised accused
some people wait four hours to play this
right now and it's like eight o'clock at
night so there's still tons of people
trying to play it but I mean I
definitely enjoyed it it's definitely a
call of duty one thing that really stood
out to me is the wall run but it's
really really well done in black ops 3 I
think that it kind of feels like it
lasts longer it doesn't feel like a
gimmicky thing you know I don't know
that I get into college this but I still
definitely enjoyed what I did plan it
and I was surprisingly not as bad as I
expected myself
a 1.5 mbta the wall simpler way
a xbox yet they also have to write up
but I've seen that demo in it it
basically looks the same that the
gameplay we've seen at e3 so I don't
think that I'll really get too much out
of playing it
it is now time for you be explored a to
have just walked into the pole again a
little bit funny today but not quite as
quiet as yesterday
but you know there's not much left that
I actually really want to play so I'm
going straight Michaela
halo five doggies but I feel like me to
talk about that adequately it probably
needs an entirely separate video because
oh my god it's so different from the
halo that I grew up playing played a
match that has something called breasts
which basically like you when you get to
a certain level and the level is based
on each individual match so in that
match I was level six meses I lost
something new that I could spawn with
like a ghost or a banshee or a shotgun
or an energy sword which totally changes
the way the halo please I mean it was
cool but it was so different I
definitely enjoyed it though but a
bubble up we actually had the xbox elite
controller and that's the first time
that I've held one it's definitely
comfortable the grips better it feels a
little bit later but there's a lot of
buttons on it that you can feel at all
times even when you don't impress them
and it seems like the d-pad little
bigger fighting games but it's very
precise so I think I need a little bit
more time with that to actually figure
out how I feel about it
you
come on me right now is the room for
halo covenant ela which i think is
incredibly cool respectively an Afghan
but it's made by / info and the needles
are the top that stick up a pataga
actually light up which are your bullets
they also stick so they will actually
stick certain things and get them with
seals and targets and stickers or
but halos incredibly cool thing
the closest that we can currently get to
really
time at CB Expo 2015 completed I played
everything that I wanted to play which
was a weirdly large brown shoes i still
had a lot of fun spent a lot of today
meeting a lot of you guys which is
always really really awesome and
definitely my highlight of pdx boat
trips so thank you to every single
person who came and said hi and well if
you say nice things so thank you for
that um but it's time for me to go back
to Brisbane and I will see you next time
that there's a convention which will
hopefully be pax Australia thank you
guys watching